اعلن المتحدث باسم جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ان الطائرات حربيه اسرائيليه
اغارت فجر اليوم على موقع تحت الارض تابع
لحركه حماس وسط قطع غزه لانتاج ما وصفها
بالمواد الخام الصاروخيه واضاف المتحدث في
بيانا الغرضه تاتي ردا على صاروخ اطلق نحو
المناطق الاسرائيليه امس وحمل حركه حماس
مسؤوليه كل ما يحدث انطلاقا من قطاع غزه
متواعدا بان تدفع ثمن اي انتهاك وافادت
مصادر الفلسطينيه النمر وحيات حربيه شمر
ثمان غارات على اهداف في المحافظات هي
الوسطى وكذلك في شمالي مدينه غزه
في هذه الاثناء اعلنت كتائب والمقاومه
الوطنيه الجناح العسكري للجبهه
الديمقراطيه لتحرير فلسطين مسؤوليتها عن
قصف مستوطنات غلا في غزه برشخه صاروخيه
فجر اليوم وقالت الكتائب في بيان لها ان
هذا القصف ياتي ردا على العدوان
الاسرائيلي بحق ابنائه الشعب الفلسطيني في
غزه والضفه وقد بثت هيئه البث الاسرائيلي
فيديو لما قالت انه اعتراض القبه الحديديه
لصواريخها وثيقه من قطع غزه باتجاه
مستوطنه غلاف غزه عقب الغارات الاسرائيليه
على القطع
من غزه ينضم الي مراسل الجزيره هي شامه
زقوط مرحبا هشام ضعنا في صوره مفصله لما
حدث
محمد القصف الاسرائيلي استهدف احد مواقع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في الجنوب الغربي
لمدينه غزه انفجارات عنيفه سمع دويها في
جراء هذه الغارات التي نفذتها طائرات
الاستطلاع المسيره وكذلك الطائرات الحربيه
المقاتله سلسله من هذه الغارات الجويه
شنتها الطائرات الاسرائيليه على هذا
الموقع المصادر الامنيه تحدثت عن اكثر من
ثماني صواريخ اطلقتها الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه الامر الذي احدث اضرار جسيمه
في هذا الموقع المستهدف والمناطق المحيطه
به السيارات الدفاع المدني وكذلك سيارات
الاسعاف هرقت هرعت الى المكان وعملت على
تمشيط المناطق المحيطه للبحث عن اي اصابات
في تلك المنطقه ولكن لم تعلن الجهه
المختصه عن وجود اي اصابات جراء هذه
الغارات من المعروف ان الاجنحه العسكريه
للفصائل الفلسطينيه وفي ظل الاوض
الميدانيه المتوتره تعمد الى اخلاء
مواقعها تحسبا لاي قصف اسرائيلي وهو ما
جرى من جهته الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن عن قصف
موقع يتبع لحركه حماس في غزه وقال ان
القصف ياتي ردا على صواريخ اطلقت من
القطاع يوم السبت الماضي باتجاه بلدات
غلاف غزه رغم ان اي من الفصائل الفلسطينيه
المعروفه لم تصدر اي تعليق على او اعلان
او تبني لهذه الصواريخ التي اطلقت اول امس
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه قصفت كذلك ثلاث نقاط
رسم تتبع للمقاومه الفلسطينيه قرب الحدود
الاسرائيليه مع قطاع غزه وبحسب المصادر
الامنيه المدفعيه قصفت نقطه رصد شرق بلده
بيت حانون شمال القطاع ونقطتي رست شرق
مدينه خان يونس جنوب القطاع المقاومه
كتائب المقاومه الوطنيه الجناح العسكري
للجبهه الديمقراطيه تبنت اطلاق صواريخ
باتجاه مستوطنات غلاف غزه
ان اطلاق هذه الصواريخ جاء ردا على
العدوان الاسرائيلي بحق ابناء الشعب
الفلسطيني في غزه والضفه الغربيه سمع كذلك
اصوات اطلاق نار وانفجارات ويبدو انها
كانت ناجمه عن اطلاق كتائب القسام الجناح
العسكري لحركه حماس النار من مضادات ارضيه
واطلاق صواريخ ارض جو باتجاه الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه التي اغارت على موقع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهذا السلاح اعلنت
كتائب القسام عن استخدامه عده مرات خلال
هذا العام للتصدي للطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه صافرات الانذار اطلقت في
بلدات مناطق غلاف غزه واعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن ذلك دون توضيح سبب اطلاق
هذه الصافات وهل هي ناجمه عن اطلاق صواريخ
من غزه ام انها اطلقت جراء اطلاق النار
واطلاق صواريخ ارض جو باتجاه الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيلي الاسرائيليه التي نفذت
الغارات على الموقع التابع للمقاومه الف
لكن لعل البارز في هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي
الذي يمكن القول عنه انه حتى الان محدود
انه جاء بعد اكثر من يوم من اعلان الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن سقوط صاروخ اطلق من غزه
باتجاه منطقه نحل عوز القريبه من القطاع
وقد عقد الكبنه الاسرائيلي اجتماعا امس
لمناقشه الاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
ويبدو انه اتخذ قرار القصف خلال هذا
الاجتماع في مرات سابقه كان الجيش
الاسرائيلي ينفذ غارات بعد عده ساعات فقط
من اعلانه سقوط صواريخ على بلدات غلاف غزه
وفي العاده هذه الغارات تستهدف مواقع
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه لكن رغم كل ذلك يمكن
القول ان كل ما يحدث حتى الان هو في نطاق
قواعد الاشتباك المعروفه بين الفصائل
الفلسطينيه والاحتلال الاسرائيلي بمعنى
انه طالما ان الطائرات الاسرائيليه تقصف
مواقع بعيده نوعا ما عن التجمعات السكنيه
دون وقوع اصابات او قتلى يرجح عدم تطور
الاوضاع الميدانيه لكن في ظل التطورات
المتسارعه والانتهاكات الاسرائيليه في
الضفه الغربيه والقدس وحتى في السجون
الاسرائيليه والاعتداءات على الاسرى
الفلسطينيين يمكن ان تتصاعد الاوضاع في
ايه لحظه منذ عده اسابيع الاوضاع
الميدانيه تشهد توترا وعلى التصريحات من
الفصائل الفلسطينيه والتهديدات من هذه
الفصائل التي قالت انها تراقب عن كثب
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه في الضفه الغربيه
ومدينه القدس والجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن خلال
الاسابيع القليله الماضيه عن سقوط عده
صواريخ على بلدات غلاف غزه بشكل متفرق
وقصفت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه مواقع
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه عده مرات في غزه خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه وهذا ربما ما دفع الوسط
بين الفصائل الفلسطينيه والاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لتكثيف اتصالاتهم ومحاوله منع
تدهور الميدانيه وانزلاقها الى مواجهه
جديده وكانت هناك عده زيارات من قاده
الفصائل الفلسطينيه الى القاهره الامين
العام لحركه الجهد الاسلامي زياد النخاله
ورئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس اسماعيل
هنيه زاروا القاهره على راس وفود من هذه
الفصائل بدعوه من مصر
لمناقشه التطورات في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وبحث مقالات ما قد يجري في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه لا سيما في قطاع غزه في ظل
الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه المتواصله شكرا
معي من غزه